the most powerful way
and the easiest way to change your
thermostat setting is by adding people
to your circle
very close proximity that live at a
higher temperature in that area than you
do your behavior is way ahead of your
success without acceptance when bad
things happen
there's no optimism without optimism
there's no action and without action
there's often no victory want to be
happy build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one make a commitment with vuci
tembaqueo if you study
people who are at the pinnacle of
anything
you recognize that to get there
motivation was maybe one percent of the
formula maybe
one percent
and i'll prove it to you
if you want to become a world-class
bodybuilder say an ifbb pro
what that takes is you have to train
twice a day
six days a week
you have to have eight meals a day
your calorie intake is regimented your
meals are pre-planned and pre-cooked
you don't eat according to taste you eat
according to function
so my trainer for instance will eat and
i'm going what are you eating
and he's having the most he'll have
chicken that was boiled without salt
and he'll have like half a kilo of it
what are you doing
he says i'm taking in protein he doesn't
say i'm eating he says i'm taking in
protein
for him it's functional it's not taste
based
then
you will probably have to train for a
minimum and this is if you are a genetic
phenom
you'd have to train for a minimum of 10
years
before you could get on a stage
and compete at an average level with an
average global bodybuilder average
okay
so why am i say why am i telling you
this
all all of us here at the beginning of a
new year write these things called new
year's resolutions
and then it you you know you new year's
resolutions number one make more money
yeah
uh number two
uh
change my boyfriend
number three get into shape
yeah number three
get into shape is somewhere in the top
three
so what do you do you go to the gym you
get a gym membership
yeah
you buy
you go to the local nike store and you
buy like all of your gym gear
you are motivated you are inspired you
are going to the damn gym
you go to youtube you subscribe to all
of the fitness channels you go to
instagram you follow all of the fitness
models you are motivated you are going
to the damn gym you're going to get in
shape
that's what you're gonna do
the people you're following on youtube
have been working on for a minimum of
five years to look like that
so you have the incorrect understanding
that after a month of working out you're
going to look like them
so what happens in the first month
you're excited you go to gym every
single month
you know and you take the pains and your
body is sore but you know i'm excited
i'm going to gym then life happens
company doesn't make money you don't
make your targets you fall a bit ill
something happens and all of a sudden
you stop going to gym for a day a day
becomes two two becomes a week now all
of a sudden you've had a gym membership
for three months and you haven't been in
that time
what did you miss you thought motivation
was the formula winners don't need
motivation winners need discipline
disciplines about getting it done
because it needs to get done not because
i feel like it
not because i'm motivated for it
you think nelson mandela is motivated to
spend 27 years in prison
do you think martin luther king was
motivated to march across the states and
proclaim freedom
do you think you know if you look at
people to change the world they're not
doing it because they're motivated
they're doing it because they made a
commitment to do it and they disciplined
to see it through
discipline is far more important than
motivation
which is why you've got to be careful
the decisions you make because once you
make that decision you have to see that
decision through
like my mentor says first we make the
decisions then the decisions make us
so you got to be very careful the
decisions you make be very careful the
commitments you make
motivation i'm telling you now is
completely overrated
it's important don't get me wrong
you know we meet according to motivation
we feel good rara
but that'll fade
you need a stronger will and a deeper
commitment to see things through habit
number two choose who you associate with
with ed milette the most powerful way
and the easiest way to change your
thermostat setting is by adding people
to your circle
very close proximity that live at a
higher temperature in that area than you
do for example in your faith let's just
say you're a 75 degree or in your faith
you've already seen this you can't
possibly begin to regularly associate
with good godly people who pray
regularly who try to live righteously
and there are 110 120 degrees of of
faith in their life and not have that
proximity heat you up now you won't get
to where they are you'll get to
somewhere between where you are at 75
degrees and they are at 110 over time
you become 100 degree and you alter the
thermostat setting through association
same in business if you and i were to
hang around each other every single day
and let's say you were a 75 degree or in
business hypothetically and i don't know
that about you but let's just say you
were
and i was 150 degree and we hung around
each other all the time don't you think
through that association especially if
you had two or three or four people like
me in your life that just over time you
don't even feel it you're at 80 you're
85 you're at 90 you're at 95
and that's where you are we understand
the power of this with our children
because we know at school the teachers
have influence over them they're mentors
but the people that really have
influence over our children are for
their friends because they're around
them all the time and so we know it sets
their temperature this is true in
fitness if you're a 75 degree of fitness
at every meal every day at the gym all
your associations hypothetically
speaking we're with someone who was
shredded and fit the way you wanted to
look at 150 degrees you know over time
you get heated up and so you can't be
with someone every day you can't be with
them all the time but the key is to get
more proximity in the areas that matter
with people whose thermostat setting is
higher than yours i am a product you are
listening to me right now because i've
been so obsessed with this concept of
adding new associations to my life that
live in the areas that i want to improve
in at higher temperatures than me it's
my obsession to this day i'll give you a
secret one of the reasons i even do my
show is i know that i'm influencing many
of these guests in the areas that matter
most to them through our proximity and
in some cases they do it for me and so
i'm obsessed with the power of
association but i don't just associate
see
all personnel says yeah you're the five
people you hang around
kinda
you really are the five to ten people
you hang around if you're conscious all
the time
of studying them of observing them of
asking questions of the fact that you
should be altering your thermostat
setting that's when it really moves it's
not just hanging around it's consciously
and intentionally spending time with
people
where you allow it to impact you where
you study them where you really observe
them where you're open to their
influence there has to be a level of
trust before you can do that where you
surrender yourself to them but it's not
just being around them it's
intentionally being around people that
alters that thermostat setting so power
of association is the main way to do it
how about number three find your rocket
ship with sheryl sandberg i was at the
treasury i didn't really ever think i'd
live in california but from the point of
view of the u.s treasury all the
exciting stuff was happening out here in
these companies that didn't exist and so
i wanted to work in silicon valley
um but it was actually hard it was 2000
2000 2001.
lots of people said i would never hire
anyone like you to my face
there was a huge bust the tech first
tech bubble had just burst
and so it was actually hard to get a job
and when i finally got one at google it
felt like the wrong job i had a
spreadsheet some of you have those it
had my criteria for my jobs
and the problem with the google job is
other than loving the company it met
none of the criteria
i was a business unit general manager
but you know i'm not that dumb there
were no business units so that didn't
job title didn't mean anything
it was also a couple levels lower
than other job offers i had elsewhere
and eric did he put his hand on my
little spreadsheet when i showed him my
criteria and how google met none of it
except that i loved the company
and said you love the mission
this is a rocket ship when you get
offered a seat on the rocket ship you
don't ask what seat
and this is one of the most common
career mistakes i see people make all
the time i'll have someone coming out of
government or someone who's in legal or
someone who's in marketing and they want
to change careers
they want to move from marketing to
sales that's not hard maybe it's not a
good example from legal to marketing or
from politics or industries and then
you'll say okay we're willing to take a
chance on you you'll start here and
they're like but that's three levels
lower or two years behind
and i'm looking at them i'm like if
you're going to work for the next 40
years why do you care
get yourself and the job i took at
google and the job i took at facebook
were more junior than every other job
offer i had right
but they turned out to be much bigger
opportunities
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four adjust your
behavior with trevor moad we both grew
up in tacoma
and there used to be a thing called
toastmasters i don't know if you
remember toastmasters but toastmasters
was a local regional and a national
speaking group for anybody that wanted
to get better at speaking
well my dad had gone to a toastmasters
early on and heard one of the most
successful magazine entrepreneurs in the
world speak he comes back and tells me i
just had a chance to hear one of the
most successful magazine entrepreneurs
in the world
speak and he said when are you taking
your s.a.t i said i'm taking it next
year he said well this guy was failing
out of high school he was struggling he
was raised by a single mom in the
midwest but he promised his mother he
would take a test called the s.a.t
so he takes the s.a.t in may's junior
year doesn't expect anything get to
score back in june now the s.a.t which i
don't know how many your population know
but it's it's a standardized test with
the math part and a verbal part both are
scored out of 800 points well this guy
takes it he's bombing he's failing out
of school he doesn't expect anything as
he's telling the story of toastmasters
well he gets a 1480 out of 1600.
so he's stunned right that would be for
the smart people that listen you're
probably saying yeah right cognitive
dissonance so i got a 900 on my sats
just to give people a friend right and i
got a 10 90 and i got a 10 10. right i
was just hey four digits it was a
miracle right and and but it's a hard
test and you you know it's a variety of
different things so he gets the score
and his mother doing what any mother
would do knowing her kids says did you
cheat right she knows her son and he
said i swear to god i tried to cheat but
the way the numbers were and the
scantrons and the bubbles you couldn't
cheat so she says you mean to tell me
you really got that score he said yeah i
got the score so he's stunned tom so as
my dad telling me the story i'm like
okay so he says all right so what he
decides is because he realizes he's
smart and he's going into his senior
year he says i'm going to go to class
now he starts to go to class he doesn't
hang out with who he did when he didn't
go to class
all right teacher see him in class and
they said hey maybe franklin pierce
maybe we missed the boat on this kid so
they start to treat him differently well
as the guy would tell the story he
graduates goes to a community college
goes on to wichita state goes under the
ivy league and becomes this massively
successful magazine entrepreneur so i
said okay well the guy was always smart
he just needed a standardized test to
unlock it my dad said no that's not the
story and this is what i want you to
understand
he said 12 years after all this guy's
success he gets a letter in the mail
from princeton new jersey doesn't think
anything about it the next day his wife
says you're going to open it he opens it
true story turns out the s.a.t board
will periodically review their test
taking procedures and the policies the
year he took the test he was one of 13
people
sent the wrong s.a.t score
his actual score was a 740 out of 1600
and he said people think my whole life
changed when i got to 1480. but what
happened my whole life changed when i
started acting like a 1480 and what does
a 1480 do he goes to class
well this is one of the first stories i
would share when i had my opportunity at
alabama or florida state or georgia so a
your language is powerful but number two
your behavior is way ahead of your
success
and so many people let their feelings
dictate what they do as opposed to throw
your behavior out there russell wilson's
510 he shouldn't be playing pro football
but he behaves like the best quarterback
in the country and he's done that since
before he was at that level and then his
feelings and emotions and his skill
caught up to that behavior i think the
lesson my dad was trying to teach me
ultimately was in addition to my
language what i do
not how i feel about my past is going to
determine who i am in the future and
that's what i think neutral thinking is
and i think neutral thinking isn't just
thinking i think it's behavior and i
think it's language and so your behavior
is what's going to change you
but
you also have to start by asking
yourself what do i want and why do i
want it why don't i have it
you know what am i willing to do to get
it how about number five work in a team
with mark zuckerberg there's a little
bit of this cultural bias towards
thinking that you know one person does
this right i mean people say that you
know i built facebook or steve jobs
built apple or whatever but you know
that's really not true right i mean it's
we're we're people we we helped uh but
there were thousands and thousands of
other people involved in building these
things and the reality is is that as
strong as any one individual is
no one person can deal with all the
challenges that are going to get thrown
at them in anything that you do
and
one of the ways that i think we maintain
resilience is by having
co-founders and partners who
complement our strengths and
fortify our weaknesses and can kind of
encourage us and give us a push to to
keep going when things are tough and
there's actually a lot of data on this
that suggests that companies that get
started with more co-founders are more
likely to be successful
and it isn't quite clear
exactly from that data why that's the
case although it is very clear in terms
of the outcome for the startups that it
is the case um but i would guess
that the reason why that's the case is
because of this resilience point where
people who start something by themselves
i just think like there's no way that
any one person can overcome all of the
different things that you need to do to
build a startup or take on any kind of
other project in the world but if you
have two or three or four partners then
i don't know i mean maybe over time one
of them
doesn't like it and drops out but you
still have enough strength on the team
to power through all the challenges that
you have and that's kind of how you go
and you know at facebook today one of
the things that i always find a little
bit
funny is again that so much attention is
placed on on me is the person running
the company whereas i think you know
people like cheryl
who really you know is my partner
running the whole business or you know
folks like chris cox who run a huge
amount of our product or uh mike
schrepfer who's our chief technology
officer and and kind of make sure that a
ton of uh what we're doing works or jay
parikh who you know runs all of our
global infrastructure and in all the
data centers around the world
we couldn't make facebook work without
those people right and and there were
really hard days where or i'm not sure
what to do next and and they keep me
going habit number six get into
immediate rapport with jordan belford
first goal
in any conversation which you must do
you must
get into immediate
i'm going to use a word it's a big word
we've all heard before it's called raw
rapport
with the straight line
the first thing you're going to learn to
do using tonality and certain words
we'll go through this afternoon
you're gonna learn how to get into
immediate rapport
on both a conscious
and
an unconscious level conscious so yeah
wow it makes sense to them
and unconsciously like i just kind of
like that guy i can't tell you exactly
why but he sounds sharp it sounds like a
winner
you need to get into
instant rapport immediate rapport on
both a conscious and unconscious level
so
you can then open them up
to being essentially what's called
qualified
so you can actually find out
and in the straight line qualifying is
about not just what their needs are
it's their needs
what any pain they have in they might
have
okay we gather intelligence we don't
just identify needs we gather
intelligence
you do that
by getting into rapport with someone
first it's not like let me gather
intelligence first and then get into
rapport the first thing you need to do
using tonality in certain words we're
going to learn how to do it is to get
into immediate rapport
and then use that rapport
to gather intelligence and move them
down the straight line and habit number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is create hope with
stephen bartlett uncertainty is not
predictable but it's preparable and i
don't actually think that's a word but
here's what i mean
what i know for sure and this relates to
everybody is that your life is of course
going to be full of a lot of joy and
amazing things in breathtaking moments
and rapturous moments of of ecstasy
right but it's also going to be riddled
with moments of
unexpected uncertainty and chaos joy is
much easier to handle you just kind of
let go and go with it right the good
times you have not a lot of action or
thought required but uncertainty and
chaos require a real rigid set of
principles and for me those principles
over the last 12 months have become
acceptance optimism and action and these
three principles have a real linear
connection to the outcome you're seeking
without acceptance when bad things
happen
there's no optimism without optimism
there's no action and without action
there's often no victory or at least
victory is delayed and hard times are
elongated so when bad news visits
whether that's being unexpectedly fired
from your job or dumped by your partner
or evicted by your landlord or losing a
loved one in the case of a pandemic you
have to do everything you can to stick
to these principles despite the intense
cloud of natural emotions that will try
to convince you and me otherwise and you
know like i do
a lot of sort of introspective thinking
for a living and even i am not
immune
from letting emotion get the best of me
in times of intense chaos i like no
matter how much i've read or written in
my diary or how many podcasts i've done
even i
fall victim especially in the short term
to all of those emotions and sometimes
to the the instructions those emotions
give you which will lead you to um to
pretty dire outcomes so you know you get
dumped by your partner you immediately
think revenge right you get fired by
your boss you think um you know i'm
gonna sue them right i fall for those
traps too and i don't think i don't
necessarily think it's
the aim of all humans should be to try
and avoid those emotions and that
thinking because i think it's quite
impossible but it's to be better at the
response right to shorten the time that
those emotions sit with you and to be
better in your reaction and i want to
clarify that acceptance when i talk
about acceptance it doesn't mean being
emotionless it can often mean the exact
opposite you have to accept how you're
feeling except what's happened
and importantly retire from trying to
change the unchangeable or from
wallowing in regret and you have to do
everything you can to get yourself to a
place of optimism i see that as your
responsibility people won't like me
saying that right people typically
especially in hard times don't like to
delegate responsibility to themselves so
as hard as it can be you have to find
and create hope for yourself and have
faith just like everything else has in
your life that this too shall pass
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that that's not good enough
no not for you believe nation we got to
do something but when you write it down
and you create a specific plan of action
for the next week that number jumps to
91 chance of you following through and
when you commit to somebody else like
leaving a comment on this video it jumps
to 95 you need to follow through on your
goals so what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your
specific plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you you are capable
of more i just want to tell you to
remind you that you are capable of more
that this struggle that's in front of
you right now that seems
all-encompassing and impossible to
overcome it's not your max
you can handle it because if this is
your max then you don't grow and you
don't become the person that you know
you're capable of becoming this video
will help so the most pain i went
through was when i was on my tour last
year and i broke my neck i broke my neck
i i fainted and and hit my head on the
wall and and broke my neck in two spots
i compressed my spine i had a concussion
which i've never had in my life before
and i had to they put me in a neck brace
they put me in these and i wore this one
for
50 days or so and this one for 10 or
something like that it was 60 days of of
wearing something like this and
only be able to take it off for 10
minutes a day
that's it so i had to sleep in this i
had to i had to shower in this i had to
do my speaking gigs in this and you can
see i don't know if you can see this
duct tape on here because this one was
more comfortable than this one and so
like i really didn't want to break this
one but just from use right from having
it on all day long eventually it broke
and my wife taped it up and she wrote
here i love you get well soon love nina
kind of like a cast
anyway this is the most painful thing
that i had to go through and the day i
broke my neck i was supposed to be doing
my speaking gig in in colorado and we
had to cancel that because obviously i
can't do it while i'm in the hospital
but then
came a really important time
what do i do next i don't know how
long a concussion lasts i don't know how
i'm going to deal with the pain i
haven't really broken a bone in my body
before let alone two in my neck i didn't
know how safe it was to travel still did
my speaking gigs and the advice was rest
and go home you can't get on a plane
because of the compression but just just
drive home just rest and go home
and you know my agent wanted me to do it
the doctors want me to do it i'm not
gonna go home i don't want to go home
this is my chance to show myself what
i'm made of this is my chance to see
what i can do i'll let me at least try
let me at least try and it's very rare
that we actually get pushed to our
limits like our actual limits you're
pushed to your physical limits and you
can't do anything more and so my initial
thought was well forget that i mean
let's just
everybody who was supposed to come let's
just do something tomorrow
this is what i was thinking let's do
something tomorrow in our airbnb
and just have them come over and i'll
lie down on the couch or the bed and
they can ask me questions
i'm here to give value guys i'm here to
help let's go helping entrepreneurs is
going to be healing for me and the
doctor like yeah you can't do that you
you got a concussion you can't even
think clearly or properly like that's
never gonna happen so i had to refund
everybody in colorado and um and my next
stop was kansas city
and we drove to kansas city not too far
away and
i was still
feeling the massive pain from the
from the neck
but still the concussion i hadn't
recovered from my concussion and i
didn't know how long it was going to
last and i made a video
for the people who bought tickets in
kansas city canceling on them
and what i wanted to do was say hey i'm
here anyway
i'll give you your money back come to
the hotel
and i'll i'll still talk to you for as
long as i can go
and it was the morning
the day before in the morning and i was
making a video i thought
i couldn't even finish making a video
i started getting dizzy halfway through
the video and so i i paused it and i
thought okay we should just we should
just cancel this like i i can't even get
through
uh two minutes of making a video
and so i tried again at night and i got
through the video and i said you know
what i don't know how long it will last
tomorrow i already booked a hotel
you know i'm not it's not it's
non-refundable for me
you guys already booked your tickets you
booked the time off in your calendar i'm
going to refund you the money because
i'm not going to go for four hours like
i've been doing in each city but
i'll go for as long as i can
if you want to show up and and i'll try
to help
and i went
for an hour and a half and it was the
greatest hour and a half
you know one of the greatest hour and a
half of my life and and my wife had to
then pull me off after an hour and a
half because i certainly get i didn't
even notice it but i was starting to get
you know woozy on stage
and um it was great i was so pumped
because this was this was i'm done i've
never been pulled off a stage before
and here i was at my max
and i love the idea of pushing through
the pain obviously be healthy obviously
don't be stupid
but a lot of times we pull ourselves
back way too soon we don't allow
ourselves to actually test what we're
made of to see how far we could actually
go
and so i kept these
thanks to my friend mark draker i don't
collect things um i don't i don't have
souvenirs of stuff but he said you need
to collect you need to save them as a
souvenir of what happened as a memento
like all right whatever i'll keep it and
i look at this i'm like i'm crazy i did
that
60 days in this and kept going on tour
and we still did 10 more cities and i i
sat at the front of these stages
sitting down because i couldn't stand
properly and i had had like two or three
pillows behind me and an ice pack over
my right shoulder the whole time and and
still spoke for three to four hours
every day right
i still made videos you can go back on
my channel and you'll see me wearing
this with like this giant scab or scar
in my head because this is where i hit
my head on the wall
it's crazy this is a reminder of what
i'm capable of that whatever max i feel
like i'm facing right now is not my max
and i think you're capable of more as
well when i left television news i
thought that was my dream job that was
what i was going to do my whole career
but sometimes knowing when to let go of
a dream isn't quitting it's actually the
victory it's like that knowing of when
to let go of a dream as important as
knowing when to go after one we are in
this really huge secular transition away
from degrees towards skills
it no longer matters where you went to
school what you did don't tell me you
have an mba it's irrelevant it's useless
who gives a sh
learn to code and you'll be employed for
the rest of your life i lost a kid 24
year old kid to a big company in
cupertino
where he got paid 175 grand a year and
600 000 guaranteed over four years in
rsus
and this he's not done anything ever
okay
so all of you should teach your kids how
to code
all of you you should learn how to code
but my point is it's about skills now
and so that's another reallocation of
trillions of dollars going back to
your book i think that one thing that's
really really interesting about it is
the way that you structure it around
like 80 of the book is the excuses that
you you literally tackle them one by one
i thought was really smart and then
skill acquisition yeah so
why why that structure why excuses and
skills because that well the excuses are
just what i hear all day from women in
dms and emails standing in line a book
signing it's all the reasons why they
can't do what they want to do and um
makes my head explode because it's like
what like you're not
it drives me crazy so i thought it's
well and good for us to talk about the
things that you need to do to achieve
this stuff but none of this matters if
you don't have this foundational
like presence of mind to get out of your
own way and to stop using that as a
crutch for why you can't
do what you want to do if i get flack
for anything in this space it's the idea
that i tell women that anybody can
accomplish anything and i really believe
that to the marrow of my bones because
there is no reason that i should have
the life that i have the business i've
built the
being on state like i shouldn't have any
of this this is
working
every single day for the last 15 years
to achieve the thing that i want to
achieve you had said something recently
or maybe it was on your instagram where
someone said like how do i become a
speaker and you were like speak
everywhere everyone go everywhere
that
people like oh i would love to be a
speaker but i can never talk like you
and i'm like
i spoke at old folks homes i spoke
because they can't run away by the way
if anyone needs this tip the people
laugh i'm like no was for real mops
groups which is mothers of preschoolers
they exist all over the country
i'd speak at the opening of an envelope
and i was horrible like my first
speeches it was this maybe something it
was like
and it's so embarrassing and you know
your hands are shaking and i had note
cards and i keep the videos on youtube
because i want people to see the
progression of what a decade looks like
i've done it so much you need me to do a
keynote right now i got you i can make
it up
but it didn't start that way it was so
many years and so much effort and the
problem is
people don't they're like well i can't
because or here's the reason why i'm
like yeah me too
i had all those excuses and it didn't
mean that making the decision to move
forward
suddenly it got easier
if anything making the decision to move
forward is harder like because now um
john maxwell said this to me the other
day he's like which is the most named
drop you think but i was interviewing
him on the podcast we're not like you
know having a slumber party but he said
um movement causes friction
always and so it's you it just because
you make the decision to move forward
doesn't mean it you know now we're now
we're doing it no now you've got all
kinds of other problems so excuses were
really important for me to tackle just
because
i i think
love my girls but women especially like
we need to call bs and you need to have
someone
get in your face and say like with all
the love in my heart this is not this is
not real this is something that you've
decided to cling to because it justifies
why you're still in the same place i'll
ask you a very simple question
why does your organization
exist we don't need you clearly there's
plenty of competition clearly people
have plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do a reasonably
good job they might even be better than
you in some areas so why do you exist
providing education is table stakes
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that that's why the industry exists
not why your organization exists
that's like when i talk to healthcare
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you
but i know that the culture of one
organization is different than the
culture of another organization
there are cultural norms that wrap
around the sense of purpose cause or
belief
great organizations understand their
just cause a cause so just
that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause sacrifice comes in many forms it
might mean um working longer hours
giving you my best ideas turning down a
better job that offers me more money to
stay here because i believe in what
you're doing and i want to see that
advanced
one of my favorite
examples of a just cause
is
the declaration of independence
our founding fathers
declared literally wrote down they
declared why
we needed our own country
all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
amongst which include life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
they were never against britain
the whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they won independence there are always
finite games within the infinite game
though they won independence
that didn't mean that they had now
provided all men are equal now the real
heavy lifting began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
revolutionary war george washington
understood how limiting that was and he
realized that they had to have a broader
definition
so he included catholics
he banned any organizing against
catholics and his armies and he would
regularly attend mass to send the right
message
some time later
we abolished slavery
and the 14th amendment
some time later we had women's suffrage
sometime later we had
civil rights act sometime later we
implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving
to provide this thing called all men are
equal people are equal and though we
will never actually get there we will
die trying and the obstacles may always
be different
and what a just cause is it is a vision
of the future that does not yet exist
and you will commit all of your energies
to advance that vision of the world that
you have
and the people you want to attract both
those who work there those who teach
there and both those who come to learn
there
believe in your vision of the future
so much so
that they may turn down a better offer
from someone else because they want to
be
around people who are committed to
building this world that does not yet
exist and every single single one of
these organizations that you
run and represent
can have different visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just cause is
what you stand for otherwise the only
thing i have to judge you on
is
superficial things
it's like dating right
it's like dating if if somebody tells me
what they stand for who they are they're
talking about their character
and those are the people we want to
spend the rest of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are what they stand for what their
purpose what their cause what their
beliefs are what their values are the
only thing we have to judge them on is
how much money they make and how good
looking they are many ideas that people
have and never actually acted on
when you first came up with the idea for
toms
was this a a big serendipitous moment
for you what was it like
you know it's funny i get that question
a lot and you know people say did you
did your life change when you thought of
toms when you had the idea and as kind
of romantic or noble as it would be to
say yes the truth is no you know it was
just an idea i mean i was running my
other business at the time and i had
this idea if i sell a pair of shoes i
can give a pair away and and and it was
just an idea but when it became much
more than an idea and when my life
really did change was when i went on
that first shoe drop you know i took my
parents who had never left the united
states before i took my brother and
sister i took you know my intern
jonathan some of my friends and we went
down there 16 people who really didn't
know each other very well and we just
got on our hands knees and started
putting shoes on kids feet and we didn't
know what we were doing i mean you know
we had the shoes made and we knew where
the areas that kids needed them but it
was an unbelievable experience to see
that just six months before that it was
just an idea and this idea had had got
it got the attention of enough people to
buy ten thousand pairs of shoes so that
they we were allowed to go there and
give them away and i'll never forget
this one moment because it really was uh
life-changing for me we were leaving a
village and i was walking away and this
woman came up and she was crying and she
was running after me and she was
speaking in spanish and my spanish isn't
very good so i went and got my partner
alejo and he's argentine and said alejo
ask her this woman what's wrong and she
had these three boys with her and they
all had brand new tom shoes on and he
said you know in spanish to her and when
she responded she started to smile
and he was smiling as he was listening
to her so before he even told me the
translation i knew she wasn't crying she
was sad she was crying because she was
happy but what she told alejo and what
he told me just blew me away she
explained that her three sons had been
sharing a single pair of shoes for the
past year
and what that meant was her oldest son
would go to school on monday he would
come home give his shoes to his brother
and have to wait until thursday to go to
school again wow i mean can you imagine
like i don't have kids but i'm sure a
lot of people in this room do i mean can
you imagine
if that was the case your family that
your children had to wait a couple days
to go to school because of a pair of
shoes
and i had no idea even when we started
tom said it was that much needed but
when that lady told alejo and he told me
and we got very emotional started crying
i mean it was like this really amazing
moment but that's when i knew that like
this is what i wanted to do with my life
in life everything's about pivoting from
one thing to another you know stepping
stones right so i started looking at the
office buildings out of this state
because california you know it's like i
gotta expand my territory
so i started going on internet thank god
to internet now you can kind of get on
there and search anything you want
so i started looking at houston fourth
largest city in the nation a lot of
movement a lot of liquidity in real
estate a lot of you know product to
cherry pick from so i started
you know teaching myself researching
different zip codes
um
you know and and i realized the area
closer to airport is very active at
businesses with a lot of people flying
for me so i stopped buying
smaller buildings you know three four
story buildings i bought three buildings
i think on my first visit i flew there
in 2004
i met with the broker he showed me five
buildings i bought three of them on the
spot
we went to his office wrote the offer
and i flew back the same day i bought it
for i think nine point seven million
dollars i put three million dollars down
but the nice thing is you know i
i had the experience already with
negotiating and adding and flipping so i
already knew
there's media on the bone on this
properties because i've already done it
you know for three four years prior
and what was nice is i bought the
buildings and then california had kind
of plateaued 2004 to 2007. you didn't
get a huge price appreciation and people
were selling in that time and doing 1031
exchange where they want to take their
money yeah arizona and houston miami new
york so houston was one of the cities
where i got a lot of california money
moving into it and i was ahead of the
curve yeah so you started trend yeah so
by 2007 i had 130 million worth of real
estate all in houston mostly all of it
in houston and i sold in 2007
most of them california buyers i start
every day with 25 things that i'm
grateful for
and all 25 things have to cost 25 or
less so i can't be grateful for my car
grateful for my home while i can be
grateful during this exercise
i'm grateful for the time that i spent
cooking in in the kitchen with my son
this weekend i'm grateful for the walks
that my grandmother takes me on i used
to say i take her on walks
then i realized she was educating me
that she takes me on walks i'm grateful
for the fact that i still dance with my
daddy
i'm grateful for the moments my nephew
climbs in my bed so we can watch our
latest greatest movie together
i'm grateful for mustard man and garlic
girl in the kitchen cooking that's my
son and i
every single thing that i find gratitude
for is something that helps to make me
who i am and i got to tell you something
happens when you live park
and stay cemented in gratitude i i call
that if your dream is the seed
then gratitude is the fertilizer
and so
gratitude constant gratitude recognizing
that you are a servant leader with a
servant's heart and when you say the
word servant servant and ego just don't
go together servant is to serve but not
a servant from a peasant mindset but a
servant from the place where you say i
choose to leave from behind i choose to
use my greatness and my light to elevate
you i choose to own my life but hand it
over to anyone who might need it in the
moment
oh
if you stay rooted in that it's a daily
thing so i recommend that you find a
daily regimen that keeps you steeped in
gratitude a daily regimen that has you
own your greatness whether it's the
reminder of the things i've just said
write the mantras out post them on your
mirror and recite them each day i live
by mantras i live by affirmations i i
designed and began to own who i was as a
woman because i kept reminding myself
daily who i could become and then one
day i went to remind myself and it stuck
i didn't need the reminder and so i
started reminding myself of something
else and i kept doing that daily daily
and then one day i want to remind myself
and it stuck
and so remind yourself of the woman the
man you're becoming
write it down write the mantra down i'm
a servant leader grateful for service i
own my brilliance unapologetically i
walk in a room and light it up with a
natural glow
i share my light with others with grace
and ease you can choose any of these
mantras you can have them all i know
you're working with some oems that you
cannot disclose with us today but but
you are working with toyota and that's
when you can uh
a relationship you can talk about what
what is the status of your work with
them and what have you learned with them
uh so far
yeah so uh you know it's we've had a
really great you know feedback loop from
from our oem customers and partners you
know this is something that uh you know
we go pretty deep on these we you know
we specifically picked um you know four
oem partners you know uh off the bat to
be able to work with and that's really
what what 2017 was about it was being
able to have it demonstrate you know the
technology really coming together in
these initial systems and getting it
deployed to you know oem partners and uh
have something where these are not just
like one-off sensor sales is something
where you know their their fleets you
know are uh committed to this and
they're committed to this type of
technology for you know autonomous
developments going forward with these
partnerships so it's been a
you know a great you know tight-knit
relationship and uh has allowed us to be
able to continuously improve our product
as we move towards they said uh you know
these lower low volume production
systems to higher volume systems for
large one larger test fleets and two you
know um you know in the in the coming a
couple of years here you know series
production you know volume products for
consumer vehicles and uh you know it's
something that requires a lot of
in-depth work and a tight-knit
relationship with the end automaker and
customer to be able to cleanly integrate
that uh volume production product for
consumer vehicles when i look at great
entrepreneurs today maybe you even and
johnny
what will make you successful is
experience that you'll take and have
those tools in your memory to use when
you have to make your pivot great
entrepreneurs do that all the time don't
let a crisis ever be wasted you learn
something from it and then you move
forward
because you might not use it that day
but you're going to use it one day and
it's going to be tremendously valuable
for you you want to know one of the
biggest secrets to sales in our world
today right now where i i believe where
we're at
is authenticity
people just want to know what's real
what's raw and they want it from your
heart
if you think about the people that
you've connected with in your life
remember this phrase
people will buy from you say yes to you
when they feel understood not just when
they understand you
i want you to listen to that again
people will buy from you say yes to you
when they feel understood not just when
they understand you
let's take let's take an example then
i'm going to circle back around with
authenticity so i'm going to park
authenticity put a pin in it and come
back to it but think about this
think about let's just say the
quintessential sales area is used cars
or new cars and i know that world is
changing but let's just talk about uh
the way it was for the last 100 years 50
years
saturday afternoon your car shopping you
pull into the dealership there's 10
dealers waiting in the window waiting
for you to come in
you pull up
one of them gets a high five your turn
go go chat with the guy in the tesla or
whatever right
now think about this scenario same
scenario
person comes up
and says hey glad for glad you're here
today nice saturday right hey listen i
just wanted to let you know
i've been selling these cars for 27
years i know i'm inside and out i've
been voted the top sales guy 14 months
out of the last five years
and it's because i care about the client
this is what i do and i can see
you're here today
and
you'd love us a sporty car but let me
guess
you want something that's a little good
on the gas maybe eco-friendly so you can
do your part i got this amazing
two-seater it's fast it's eco-friendly
it's this it's that let's go take a look
at
now that's a sales guy that could make a
job for 27 years and he wants you to
understand him
but what if
you went there that day
because you want you just had your third
child
and you want your wife to have something
that's not a minivan but the big suvs
are too clunky and you're just looking
for something in the middle nothing even
close
now that same sales person wants you to
understand him what if there's a sales
person that comes out
and you see him walking over to you and
you're like oh here comes a sales guy
you roll down your window or you get out
and he says hey listen first off i know
it's a saturday we all work on
commissions
authenticity transparency we all work on
commissions it's my turn up i gotta i
get you but i just want to tell you
let me just back up i just want to ask
why are you here today what's your
family like
what uh how can i serve you tell me a
little bit about you
and all of a sudden the person says wow
immediately who do you have rapport with
immediately
sales guy number two because he wanted
he wants you to feel understood and
probably not on purpose that's just who
he is all of a sudden you go well we had
our third kid and you go oh my god i'm
on my fourth i get it my wife hated the
minivan when i thought about bringing it
to her house she was like are you crazy
but then i looked at the monster
escalade and she's that's a bus
but we figured out something in between
would you be open to something kind of
in the middle it's kind of like the
sporty uh
smaller suv all of a sudden you're
laughing high-fiving talking about the
names of your kids what's going on in
school that playing softball or baseball
and what they do and all of a sudden
you're sitting in a car going he's a
good guy
and what did he do most of the time
he listened
he was authentic he was transparent one
of the most important things when you're
in a situation where the truth the facts
are that there is more on your plate
than one human being can effectively
handle on his or her own
there's a really important
moment where you have to surrender
to the chaos
that your life is for the next couple
weeks
things are going to change when summer
hits
but part of what i find personally
is that when i resist and i do resist
i resist what's actually happening when
that's not the way that i want things to
go
and so if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going on it's gonna
make it feel even more overwhelming
and if you can bring a sense of realism
to it so i call this and i think shawn
anchors the one that came up with this
this this term
realistic optimism
realistic optimism is a really powerful
mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin
on a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life right now
and you are
still
maintaining an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you when
you're an optimist you believe that your
actions and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle what's
on your plate you believe that based on
your thoughts and your actions you can
positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent or
terrified because you just got a scary
health diagnosis or you're spinning
because somebody just told you they
don't want to be in a relationship with
you anymore whatever it is that you're
facing that's making you feel
overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay very optimistic and
positive and know that everything that
you think and do is in your control and
that when you know that your behavior
matters it gives you a sense of
empowerment that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why
you can have a very hard life right now
and a very overwhelming life right now
and still be happy
because you know based on being a
realistic optimist that this period will
pass and you know that there are things
that you can think about and do that are
within your control today's world the
philanthropy is considered where you
give the money to someone and if you
don't give the money you are a bad
person somehow you don't care enough and
to me
philanthropy should never be about
giving money philanthropy should be
about solving a problem so this lady
came to me uh saying you know we have
done such a good job in our current
homeless shelter we really outgrown it
and now we need to expand it and we have
this capital need and we want you to
donate to it and i said instead of
asking for a donation why don't you
start to think about like a business and
i am a venture capitalist and if you
came to me
saying that give me this money that is
going to go out and do something with it
the only two choices you're giving me
either you're going to fail in doing
what you're doing in that case the money
is wasted and if you do succeed you're
going to come back and ask me for more
money so how is that going to be a
sustainable business model
and she said what do you really mean i
say ask yourself a question just like
any other business
what is
your product and who is your customer
she looked at me all she wanted to do is
write a check
and
not be interviewed and she said it's
really simple all i'm selling is the
homeless shelter the place in the
homeless shelter and my customers are my
woman who come there and i say young
lady you have a broken business model
and she said why i see your customers
don't pay you
i say they're not your customers they're
your users
and she said how would you how else
would you think about it and i said what
if just like a facebook
the social networking is not their
product the people who use social
networking is the product you and i are
the product and the customer is the
advertisers
in the same way in a women's shelter the
women are the product and local
businesses are your customers and the
more products you have the more you can
cater to the local businesses so why
don't you go to local businesses and say
i have this amazing product the women
who are so driven
that they would go out and do the things
you want them to do you will have a
loyal employee you will teach them the
skills and you will have these people
working you'll be doing good for the
society and you'll have a loyal employee
and if you do that the more people you
have in your shelter the higher the
revenue you're going to have and you'll
be continuing to expand that and just
that thought process she implemented and
suddenly now they're growing everywhere
right she actually did it she actually
did it whoa i did not think that was
going to be the punchline yeah so my
point is this is how entrepreneurs
really need to be thinking about and i
can give you several examples of that
the problem that is obvious to you may
not necessarily be the solution that
exists in that problem my father-in-law
once gave me this advice
he was the first person i met that had
really been successful and he said
what you want to do
is know more about any situation than
anyone else in the world
and i actually remember what i said to
him i said yeah my boss doesn't really
think like that
i have since apologized to my
father-in-law for giving me such an
amazing piece of information and me
doing nothing with it for like six years
but once i understood that the only path
to excellence is to truly become an
expert the only path to excellence is to
actually get good at something
these days in a hyper-connected world
where within minutes of an interaction
with you your product whatever someone
can have a global audience and tell
people what they think that product
better be awesome but the great news is
the world's been democratized now
you no longer have to have
150 million dollar ad budget in order to
cut through the clutter in our first
eight months we were profitable at month
six in our first eight months we didn't
invest more than ten thousand dollars
because we had a product that actually
delivered value
our marketing message delivered value
and if you focus on that if you focus on
making something that's better than what
other people are doing now you really
can cut through the noise very very
quickly
and you gotta grind baby grind
that was me for almost two years
people see where the company's gotten
they see me up giving speeches but what
they don't see is that in the middle of
the night my hands used to wake me up
cramping closed
because all day i was making protein
bars and in the very beginning we were
running the technology company during
the day and then going and making
protein bars by hand at night with
rolling pins and handheld blades that we
cut the bars and then wrapped them three
at a time we wrapped them three at a
time we would make 1200 bars i think
nine of us made 1200 bars over a six or
seven hour period now in a day we make
1.5 million
but that's where it starts it starts
with a willingness
to persist
long after it's boring it starts with
the ability to focus
on your end customer
long after you're exhausted it starts
with the ability to think about those
people that you really want to serve
when you're scared and have no idea how
you're going to pull it off
but you chose to believe
that you could do it you chose to
believe that and because you chose to
believe that you were able to achieve
excellence what are some key elements of
your honor code that
one are just absolutely central to it
and that two if you could pass to the
culture in an instant
what would you pass
i mean if you have an agreement with
somebody if me and you have an agreement
i don't care what the rest of the world
looks at is bad or good
we have to honor our agreement
period so honor means
that when you agree and you guys have as
men or a professional an adult
your word gotta mean more than anything
you know if you say you're gonna do
something you gotta do it
and that's what the street kind of was
you know it was like even though the
rest of the world doesn't believe in
certain things that were going on there
was this cold
you know no snitching
you know no messing with your homies
girls
no serving anyone pregnant you know just
things that were
laws that were unwritten you know
but there was honor
honor means more than anything bro and
it protects you no matter what and i
could just say that based on my
experience there ain't no street
that's just some real [ __ ] the street
might like i'm a guy that maybe i need
to see some to learn honor and maybe
that's the reason why i was put in that
situation because once i learned honor
i'd be able to affect the rest of the
world like you never know why things
happen
that's about perspective right i never
really uh did do well in television i
survived from uh
from small part to small part but my
ambition was always to do the kind of
work to play the kinds of roles that
didn't seem to occur very often in
television especially not episodic
television and episodic television i
should say has come a long way since the
days when i was doing love american
style
it must have been a really bad scene huh
what i was anxious to to do was to play
with the big boys
i wanted to do ambitious kinds of films
i wanted to uh
take on characters that were a bit more
complicated and uh and interesting i
didn't kill my wife
i don't care
and i was aware of the fact that if i
stayed
at the same place doing episodic
television over and over again i would
wear out my face i mean i don't want to
wind up like that i never get a chance
to uh
to do the kind of work i wanted to do uh
everything's under control situation
normal and because i discovered another
way of putting food on the table for my
young family uh by doing carpentry
um
i was able to wait it out
because i always knew that tenacity was
more important than almost anything else
i arrived in hollywood with the
metaphoric bus with a group of
young
people who all had a similar ambition to
mine
and as the years went by
the attrition rate eliminated many of
those uh
people from the competition pool
get off my plane
and finally there was only uh a few of
us left from that uh
entering class
and i always saw life that way that
you really had to stick it out to
prevail and along the way of course i
learned a great deal more about my craft
than i than i knew when i first started
recently you said that the biggest
mistake you've made professionally
was that
microsoft should have had the android
technology why was that the biggest
mistake
well
when you're in a field you know we were
in the field of doing operating systems
for personal computers we knew the
mobile phone would be
very uh popular and so we were doing
what was called windows mobile
we missed being the dominant mobile
operating system by a very tiny amount
we were distracted during iron and truss
trial we didn't assign the best people
to do the work so it's the the biggest
mistake i made in terms of something
that was clearly within our skill set we
were clearly the company that that
should have achieved that
and we didn't we allowed this motorola
design win and therefore the software
momentum
to go to android and so it became the
dominant non-apple
mobile phone operating system globally
so mindset without heart set is an empty
victory but then there's two more
emotional interior empires the four
interior empires
mindset plus heart set
plus health set
right vitality
like i said the hunters on the savannahs
understood they didn't understand but
the way the brain developed
was literally
if you move your natural wiring in your
brain and physiology kicks into gear
you actually bdnf promotes neurogenesis
you create more brain cells dopamine
gets released norepinephrine serotonin
you feel happier
you feel less stress
bdnf repairs damaged brain cells your
processing
heightens
you actually dial in your focus
unbelievable the benefits of exercise
but it's not and here's another key idea
on the third interior empire
health set
vitality is the dna of legendary
you cannot put a price tag on getting
into the greatest fitness of your life
and then some of you and i'm going to
work on you with great love and respect
are going to say but if i hire a massage
therapist and if i get a physical
trainer and if i get into acupuncture
and if i biohack and if i get my genome
tested to figure out my telomere so i
know my real age if i do all the things
that james
and greg are gonna talk about it's gonna
cost me a lot of money how many people
hear that or think that right now be
honest
fantastic here's a little insight just
because i love you i might not know you
but i feel love for you i'm here to
serve you i've got your back
[Music]
getting into world-class fitness will
cost you a lot of money
death will cost you more if you're not
going to train then put a sign on your
desk i quit learning a long time ago and
see how many people want to buy from
tell your family go home and tell your
wife and your kids i quit learning i
quit reading i quit studying i quit
training i can't get any better
put on there done i'm finished i'm in
retirement early i'm going to purgatory
i'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers and hope they bring me to sales
heaven
look you're done if you don't train okay
now i know you know this you've heard it
i hate to tell you this
my boy mcgregor connor
conor mcgregor or mcgregor my boy conor
mcgregor okay i went and saw him fight
in new york i went and saw him fight for
one reason because i saw him say
i'm not the best this isn't about talent
it's cause i'm obsessed i out train
everyone else i have to win so bad i
train
look if you're not training that says
something about your obsession or lack
of obsession
with winning i want you to win
i know your your wife or your husband
your spouse your family members your
kids your mom and dad want you to win at
the next level no matter what they tell
you
even if they tell you you're doing great
pat you on the back you know the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way to win is to
read the only way to win is to learn
learn more listen more
learn something new look we're in a
we're in a time like we've never been
before
technologies come and go faster than
people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or or short videos or videos
that disappear or videos this day or
text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which i've been
using a lot
look the world's changing
and if you're saying to yourself i'm too
old to learn that well then guess what
you're too old to learn that if you
can't learn anything new just put i'm
ripe and i'm about to fall off the tree
and nobody's gonna want me look man you
gotta train every single day like your
life depends on it
train every single day i am here today
i own these four companies that i own
the studio my reputation everything is
because when i was 25 years old to the
to when i was 30 years old every single
day
i trained watching video every day i'd
watch the video i'd walk in and then i
would role play and then we would do a
sales meeting every single day and
immediately immediately when i was 25
years old that is what changed my whole
life my commitment to training my
commitment and willingness to sit down
every day taking a piece of data sit
down and roll play that with somebody
else
okay look at my stats every day and on
the way home on the drive home every
single day
i would listen to audio on my way to
work every day i would listen to audio
when i woke up in the morning i watch
video every morning when i got to work i
role played every time i lost a deal i
rolled played what i would do
differently next time to get that deal
that is a commitment as millennials have
come into the workforce in large numbers
their expectations of companies have
changed they no longer look at it as
sort of a paycheck but they look at it
as how can i go to work and make a
difference in society so the notion of
purpose is becoming a much bigger factor
the big difference is that in the past
purpose used to be some sort of a
corporate social responsibility program
and typically those programs were good
people liked them
but they were at the whim or fancy of
the ceo who was there so if the ceo
retired that program got cut
so we had to weave purpose into the core
business model of the company how do you
make sure that the sense of purpose
can only be accomplished if you make
profits
and the only way to make profits is
through purpose and that's why we you
know use the term performance with
purpose linking both together and i
think that's what's uh excited
millennials in particular and what's
excited the boomers to even stay longer
in the workforce because they actually
feel they're contributing to the future
of society as opposed to walking in
picking a paycheck and leaving a
wilderness is an uncultivated
uninhabited and inhospitable region
where god has set up a place for you to
thrive
i'm gonna say that again
because i know
that most of us would want to be in a
hospitable environment
where everyone likes us and we don't
have any issues and any struggles but
what i'm telling you is that you are at
your best when you are at the wilderness
where god has created a place for you to
thrive a wilderness is an uncultivated
uninhabited and inhospitable it's
corporate america it's marriage when
you've never seen it displayed for you
before it's entrepreneurship it's an
uncultivated uninhabited no one else has
done it the way that you're going to do
it and that's why it's a wilderness no
one in the room looks like me and that's
how i know i'm in the wilderness no one
in my family thinks like me but that's
how i know i'm in the wilderness it is
an uncultivated uninhabited and
inhospitable region that god set up for
me to thrive a friend from high school
named pat who actually called me up
you know on a friday and said hey we're
gonna go jet skiing tomorrow would you
like to go on this jet ski trip and if
you don't have any money and you're kind
of in debt it's really hard to have fun
because you're always thinking about
like am i going to eat next how am i
going to pay my rent that sort of thing
and he said one thing to me that caused
me to go jet skiing he said well the guy
that owns the jet skis is a
multi-million dollar real estate
investor and you know he's going to have
one of his friends we have two jet skis
and i said yeah i'll go because i
thought to myself maybe i could talk to
this guy and i could get some advice on
what sort of business i could go into
that could maybe help me because i
wanted to go into a different industry
because i'd gotten trained and certified
in this carpet cleaning business little
entrepreneurial fantasy i had was not
working out
and so i had a finally an opportunity
when we went jet skiing at saguaro lake
which is outside of you know close to
where i live in arizona
in the phoenix area and i sat down on
the the tailgate of a pickup truck with
this real estate investor and i said to
him i said well i hear you do really
well and i have a small you know carpet
cleaning company and it's not doing that
well and i hear you you know really have
a lot of success in your business so i
wanted to ask you if you have any
recommendations of another business or
another industry that i could look at
going into uh so i can you know just
make more money and he said one thing to
me so why are there other people in your
industry that are making money and i
said well yeah there's actually a couple
of uh cleaning companies in the uh you
know phoenix area that do over a million
dollars a year and to me that's a lot of
money and he said well if there's other
people making money in the business
you're in and you're not there's nothing
wrong with the business you're in
there's something wrong with you and i
was like well no no yeah i mean that's
you know i'm ethical i don't do bait and
switch like some of these companies that
advertise a low price and a lot of these
companies are established they've been
around for a while so they have name
recognition and i would make these
excuses you say well young man you're
like many people you think the grass is
always greener on the other side and
what's going to happen if you go into
another business you're going to spend
another six months another year another
two years learning the technical skills
of another business so you can go out
and repeat the same bad business habits
that have caused you to be a failure in
the business you're in right now
now
that wasn't the motivational speech that
i was hoping for
and i've heard things like that before
but for some reason i mean everyone's
heard when the teachers when students
ready the teacher appears
and the teachers are everywhere you have
been teachers to many people you're
sitting next to many teachers this
genius network event is filled with
teachers for some reason i was receptive
to it and he said what you need to do
young man is you need to learn
fundamental business skills he said what
you need to figure out how to do is
learn how to make a business work
because if other people have learned it
and you haven't you need to learn what
it is they're doing so i got really
sunburned during that trip and i
remember driving home in my pickup truck
and i thought you know
i live in america uh i you know i'm not
the smartest guy in the world i never
got a college degree in anything i'm you
know i'm i'm an addict and that's one of
my biggest challenges as a
horrible drug addict at the age of 18.
and i was sitting there thinking but i
live in america and i got my limbs and
i'm in and there are people that don't
seem to be as smart as i think i am that
are doing far better than me what do
they know that i don't know and so i
made this decision that i am not going
to get out of this business until i
figure out how to make it work because
if i just run away from it i'm going to
try to find something else and
so what i what i did is i started
reading and it was at that point in time
that i really took reading seriously and
i said what do i need to read
that is going to give me incredible
insight be all
in
that was one of kobe's favorite words
when it related to winning he says you
have to be
obsessed with whatever your win
is and everybody looks at that word
obsessed as a bad word
as a bad word but
look at this if you weren't obsessed
would you have the guests that you have
listen
how many people do you know
you just did an interview recently with
was it tony tony and um tony robbins
russell brand yeah all right
well if people want to hear what they
have to say you have to be obsessed in
order to get that information for the
people that aren't obsessed absolutely
otherwise they wouldn't bring the
information to me
right
so they should be thankful that man
you know what
we're really really thankful that lewis
is obsessed at doing what he's doing
because it brings us enjoyment it allows
us not to be obsessed in that area and
we can be obsessed in some other area
honestly i don't judge myself like i'm
prepared for my children to say they
wish i was around more
and i'm also but i've also prepared for
them to show me that i showed them a
life of doing what you love so i taught
them how to live and that doesn't mean
about money and if they go in non-profit
politics
serving the public whatever they may do
business like like i i i think lead by
example matters yeah you know and i
think i got lucky that technology makes
me connected more than ever um and i can
physically be there way way way more
than my father was so like you know like
i i i think everyone's different and i
think you don't know you have children
that i'm this woman in the philippines i
was at a conference said something that
blew my face off which was like
she's like you know i used to resent my
mother because she was like a judge and
she worked her face off and she's like
but then
like when i got older like it's become
the foundation of my happiness she
showed me i could be independent and
have a child and i love her and it spoke
to me because the reason i don't fear
working so much and potentially missing
stuff when i'm 10 000 x more involved
than my dad was is because my dad is one
of the loves of my life yeah we have a
tremendous relationship on the flip side
i don't make the assumption that my kids
are going to see it the same way so i'm
mentally mentally prepared
for them to be disappointed oh brother
and by the way
one will be and one won't be that's so
cliche right like and so like i'm open
to that and i'm most open to adjusting
they're gonna now be eleven and eight
this summer like well maybe things
change and then by the way things change
when they get older all of a sudden you
know
the only thing i think about is sitting
courtside at nick games with my son two
times a week when he's 14 a new york
city kid grab an uber meet me at the
garden and
live life together yeah yeah you know so
like and that wouldn't have happened and
not that you need courtside
last rose great for me as well back to
the last story but let's not get it
twisted especially where my life is for
my son at 13 when he's sitting there and
russell westbrook comes over and gives
him daps he's gonna be fired up and it's
fun now what i also have to do is make
sure i don't buy him
so they become spoiled as [ __ ] so he
realizes like cool you want russell
westbrook to fist bump your son or
daughter then you better [ __ ] work i
think you'll learn more about yourself
uh if you do it that way i bought my
first stock
when i was 11. i was actually i was at
rose hill at the time and i bought three
shares of city service preferred
at uh 38 and it went down to 27 which is
something i still remember even though i
was 11 at the time
uh and then it went up to 40 and i sold
it i made five bucks on my three shares
after commissions and then it went to
200 and something so
you know i i probably remember that a
little better than if i'd been doing it
on paper
and
i fooled around doing a lot of things
between about age 11 and 19 in the stock
market i did charts i did all kinds of
technical analysis i read every book i
could get on the subject
and
i didn't do that well i didn't do
terrible but but i did i was really just
floundering around
but by
that meant by the age of 19 when i read
ben graham's book i was at the
university of nebraska in lincoln i went
and bought this book called the
intelligent investor just come out and
it had an enormous impact on me
now if i hadn't done
in the previous eight years if i hadn't
been all over the lot i'm not so sure
that that book would have had the same
impact on me i mean i was by that time i
was prepared
to read ben graham's book which changed
my life financially in an in an
incredible way i mean it
uh
uh i wouldn't be up here today if i had
read that book but yeah
part of life is getting prepared
so that
when something does happen that's
significant
you can grasp the significance of it and
know what to do with it and i would say
that first eight years of fooling around
even though it produced nothing
financially to speak of
uh produced a lot in terms of getting my
mind prepared for when i really did read
something that made sense so i was ready
to accept it and i actually went back
and
went to columbia to study under the
undergram and
uh
because of
of reading that book and all kinds of
things flowed out of it so we're
goal-oriented people yes right we played
sports you know it's all about winning
and so what i used to do is i'd attach
once i graduate high school i'll be
happy
i get a scholarship to college i
graduate all this and every time it
occurred i still was in the same state
of mind yes what i learned to do was
detach the happiness this bliss yep from
the outcome now the difference is most
people get concerned like well how can
you be motivated without an outcome no
no no i have outcomes and i pray every
morning this is a truly abundant thing
my first prayer every morning is may god
put in front of me 10 people that i can
help that you could help that you could
help that i can help and i've shifted
the paradigm of value understanding
outcomes and happiness
so i used to and maybe you'll understand
this i'm a great salesman you are i can
oversell back and sell and lie to you i
can cheat to you i've done it when i was
in my 20s i would shade the truth
you know i sold stuff sure and
it didn't make me feel good what
happened was i created a void for me to
fill all the time i'd make you promises
and i'd live on this premise i'm going
to exceed everybody's expectations
that's my goal right now let's start
first of all talk about [ __ ] yes
right how many times have you actually
in a business deal right exceeded the
other party's expectation very rarely
very rarely especially if you've set
those expectation artificially high
which i did right the way you exceeded
is by not setting them right
right not charging or selling it right
that's why i started running right but
what was cool was i started with this
prayer and i said what if i started the
day with this energy that god put a
whole bag of 100 bills in front of me
and my job all day long was to trade 100
bills for 20. so whatever i did was i
was going to provide value as a father
as a husband as a business partner as a
partner as a philanthropist and just
you'll see i ask everyone either
unconditionally how can i be of service
you do you said it to me the first time
we spoke how can i how can i be a
service i mean it yeah i know you do and
i and i know that that's my biggest
blessing i'm i'm not lazy i wake up at 4
a.m i work really hard for others and
but i also when i work hard for others i
have my intention my focus on what i
want nervous is great
it means you're outside your comfort
zone
where growth happens
did you cut your hair that looks nice
man besides you never really needed
permission to take matters into your own
hands that's jaden on his brand new drum
set
or dive head first into the unknown
jaden will officially be starring in my
next movie with me or being courageous
enough to try something new and
consistent enough to stick to it for
years even when it knocks you down
or take challenges on way bigger than
yourself this is our first bottle of
just water you feel good about it guys
this is amazing you've always had an
interesting sense of self-expression
but you take jabs like a champ and deal
them back with effortless classes it's
okay
i have a gut now right be honest
we never really understood your thing
with bugs though
seeing you roll around on the ground was
a lot cuter
when you were a baby
my dog you were nervous
shoot i was nervous
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing rich
people habits check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i actually think a lot of the
reason why great stuff gets built is
because it's kind of irrational at the
time
but so it kind of selects for the people
who care the most about it the things
that break your heart if you choose can
open your heart